mukko gigante strizzatelo katherine e
ciao a tutti
walter narisoni oggi video particolare
con tema halloween e duranti misteriosi
cioè quella volta che abbiamo addobbato
abbiamo messo un po di addobbi di
halloween come sfondo che dureranno fino
ad allora in poi gli togliamo per ora si
sa primi commenti se preferite allo
sfondo nero rispetto a quello bianco
perché magari se vi piace di più potrei
la sa propendiamo vi lascio il sondaggio
qua potete votare
potete votare adesso oppure alla fine
del video così poi vedete un po come
sistemi zucchetti un zucchetta che
domina la ruota ricevendo tanto si
camuffano bene non sono gli occhi
bianchi che noi andremo a girare la
ruota e il luca che si capita
corrisponde al quanto di halloween
attenzione perché questi quando sapranno
tanto caristi colorati in realtà sono
schifo se ti ci sono con te mostro come
sempre alla fine del video dovrete
votare il tecnico io ho servizio vitale
in volte alla mostruosità dello slide
quindi questa volta nulla bellezza
dell'hotel ma con tono time e facciamo
un mostro
quello che ci capita come sempre ma fate
un bel è che preferireste volete vedere
le altre sono le ingiunzioni e
consigliare seppure nei commenti polia
intersala in forte che cosa assieme
spada dire bancari mettetevi cori e
iniziò subito allora oggi siamo lì sono
team giallo più in viola
chi votate tiggiano di in viola in
questa volta numero 7 ci sono delle aree
particolari in parlamento non c'è
qualcosa dei dei ratti vediamo un po e
bellissimo il blu blu oceano proprio
grazie qualcos'altro dentro adesso sia
adesso proviamo a toglierlo si vedrà
sembrano piano piano forse sì ecco
arriva antica oddio
sembra un mostruoso colori vanterà
mischiate con questi due anni
eccolo lì si vede la pupilla il tuo
slime è già molto mostruoso tocca mvp
capitolo perde ma ce ne sono
ti potrei tutte interessi di a tasso
zero di esserlo già in gran numero 3
mira il sito quanto questo mi da un po
che abbiamo dentro se c'è qualche mostro
ma 30 con un dialogo quindi che tentano
di potere perché è cosa troppo con lo
sfondo nero e inquietante screen ove
dovranno votare in verità no pure
abbiamo subito dopo che questa mano vedi
un po ma abbiamo della schiuma una crema
di zucca si sembra avviata della schiuma
da barba arancione
perché figo e come essa fuori che bello
mi piace un sacco questo colore zuppa di
zucca una 20 di zucca per chiederci
questa forma ci cacciano 9 detto questo
e purtroppo io non avrò col team
arancione
[Musica]
molto interessante e molto tema ho paura
di vincere tu stai mangiando deciso che
sembra nero non viola e cos'è un piano
abbiamo dei glitter arancioni e le
conchiglie renzo miracolare bellissimo
molto meno e diventa mischiato al blu
con l'arancione
vedremo poi è uscito il colore affidati
alla sua maglietta viola mischia vediamo
non sono lei e lasciare che segue perché
carico attrezzate l'ok e floride
contenuto anche del giro gli occhi di
dio affinché danzati diavolo non diventa
nero no diventa blu scuro guarda cosa
niente non viola scuola è bellissimo
stupendo dalla numero 25 abbiamo anche
se non mi piace di ragni a me non
renderà le news live più stile halloween
ma ho paura che cosa non si accolla
machado quel sangue e offriamo il nostro
quanto sangue di ragno è meglio quel
piccolo è forse il pane arancione stream
bel rosso mi ha un po o no è caduto
impedito dentro pappetta acerbe vediamo
un quasi il ragno e mastica strada ce ne
sono altri qua decisamente ora sembra
molto più aldo windows live
anche se non la smetti fanno prolungata
e poi tutto arancione ora non mischiamo
vediamo di colori ma penso che rimanga
renzone allora il resto
mi sembrava zuppa di zucca o per un
bellissimo arancione 15 stiamo con il
tema halloween
per fortuna siamo arancione contro viola
scuro finora quale vi piace di più il
mio che bello non tutto ti vediamo
[Musica]
come non capitava una release ma quando
ti guardi quanti verdi fanno vedere
abbiamo qua dentro dentro abbiamo uno
stile classe con uno zaino un animale
feroce the tiger come si sarà mangiato
un viola con gli occhi non per l'albero
che intorno
quanto perde rimangono solo due allora
vediamo un po che animale c'è in questo
il vaccino anti a faccia una scorretta
chi lo slide
[Risate]
annunciamo klein mamma non so se
l'animale respira a poi gigante
abbondante effettivamente fa abbastanza
schifo influenzano bellissima che è
capitato a the caffe trombetta e super
allungabile questo slice questo claim
buco ora c'è l'animaletto nel mare
passando si riesce
iniziamo il genuardo non so cosa c'entri
che parlo ma è stato incastrato nel
quanto facciamo
che bello super canino ora questi
filamenti di gioco si fa questo
decisamente low kick and rise of line
dove diventa contamina che un po arriva
molto prima
veramente fa veramente paura questo
slime pack positivo ok
[Musica]
paolo ci sono degli occhi e poi sembra
davvero sa ancora guardato consistenza
perché inizia davvero il tango e poiché
occhi abbiamo di serpente gli occhi
partente è ora che non ci sta e tutto
grumoso portate sono proprio i grumi di
sangue perché in questo c'è anche la
neve finta che ha creato questi grumi di
sangue
poiché colori dipende se riusciamo a
vedere meglio gli occhi dimostra anche
altro
oddio tengo tantissimo sdran governarle
[Applauso]
si faccia lo sly un budello zoe però poi
dove maticki
[Musica]
il budello 10 e del nero le probabili
sono gli stessi colori della zucca
arancione e nero arancione e nero sì è
vero ma cosa divenga mischiato di
mettere in conto grigio proteste poi la
natura non vi capiterà indovina chi
vincerà sul sito dei colori della sua
maglietta viola nostro blog e che viola
ok vediamo come rovinerà il colore del e
del mio slime purtroppo ma cos'è la
schiuma da barba grigia perché sono i
colori di halloween però sbrancamenti
bills lago è composto da jean paul
schiuma da barba fantasma ad attivarlo
zuppetta di un po no
che aspetta forse non sta diventando
grigio o nero si è sciolto per tutto è
rimasto colore proprio in palio per me
va bene
prego 9 cos'è folla
eccola melo anthony anche colore verde
scuro o perché c'è verde acqua anche la
sopportavo le differenti sia quando
seggiano 62 cedente ma mio meglio in
verde eros pagni durante il mese proprio
nella collana non riusciva nemmeno il
mio zaino miti migliora come diventa
guardate qua c'è un mostro
decreto che ci sono dei bei colori ma
vediamo di che colore diventa blu certo
qua verde qua altro verde ovviamente ma
c'è un giallo con il verde che bello che
sarà questo slide poi qua tirò fuori il
mostro verde ancora tiriamo un po il
mostro usciranno del massimo colore che
ci stia bene
ma inquietante
il papà di che colore è diventato
consumo critico il grigio verde a
diventare curva verde con l'arancione e
con nero o di ostetricia non ti dico che
cosa sempre guarda cosa sembrano color
petrone fantastico è diventato un colore
verde
verde palude bruttissimo però il mostro
besta bensì line mostruoso tema
halloween al mio
che bello sono fiero del mio ok sono
rimasti i numeri 24 però è rimasto anche
london e lo scambio quindi vedremo il
dottor chiamo vedremo mai decollato
questo vi sembra troppo liquido per
essere gol col capo chino bert non puoi
pescare occhi aiuti che l'uomo kg gli
altri volevo qualcosa per coprirne ata
che si nota è che guardino aspetta la
graphic user aspetta
cioè chiusi vai dove i giochetti sono
però chissà chi vince oggi non è detto
sia un occhio io cerco l'occhio
[Musica]
questo è tutto campo quindi sarà un
super morbidoso nello slang super flat i
no blatter no non c'è la schiuma da
barba il fatto che la vediamo un po
guarda che bello non si sa mai
la mattina ma la cosa più strana è che
adesso tocca a te e siccome c'è solo un
guanto prenderei solo quello guarda
tanto finita perché colore magari è
scambio spesso non ho pensato no no e no
funzione tenuta mi sono calmata o no
perché io ho ingredienti qua però meglio
evitare di aggiungere questo capiti gli
occhi perché devo chiudere gli emiliani
proprio questo che ti bevi l'ultimo
verde allora non vi organizzate 341 però
una puntata tra sfortunata soldi fermi
che galleggia fermi
vediamo chi si è sfogato un po la
malizia nel verde ma non è tutto
chi è diventata la palla
deve scendere anche i vermi quelli di
ormoni
oddio scherzando con verde che schifo e
che l'altro 3 ma siamo un po per
l'amante delizioso questo togliamo è un
pezzo di dito mignolo la minestra di
halloween
chi vincerà tema il sottotitolo re di
halloween viola il rosso e verde mission
e il match tutto chissà chi vincerà
questa tesi seminato completamente nero
no sono tutte le striature guardo ok ora
andiamo ad attivarsi per castle attivano
sempre la rosetta lirici ed il rapporto
un po della palude diverte che è cascata
con doratura andiamo ad attivare liquami
facciamo vedere bene potrete decidere se
vinco io sto con gli hawks vince evitare
di miccoli miccoli è il miglior live
notare il come il colore verde tipo o
perde per te sbiadite o verde palude
verso evolute grazie mostriciattolo per
un po di st paul's cervello la cosa
positiva però è che è uscito molto più
la pink'o cicli perché c'è poca colla e
molta schiuma da barba e sharp vedette
quindi i suoni almeno sono buoni perché
noto perché il colore correndo però
nelle 31 club di halloween quindi come
colore di halloween desiste ago
c'è quel mostriciattolo quindi dategli
pure un voto da 1 a 10
in base a quanto sembra uno slide di
halloween
vediamo quello di vita le ha date lì
anche un 9 non so che nome dargli date
di bowyer noi nei commenti recco sly
[Musica]
allora facciamolo vedere bene è enorme
innanzitutto che colore è un colore
spettacolare di cosa si vedono tutti i
brillantini i brillantini rossi le
conigliette i vermi gli occhi questo lo
volevo chiamare slime quattrocchi perché
c'era un occhio quartieri 4 e allora ma
io lo chiamo quattrocchi perché due
sottili serva 6
se libero 4 a 2 chieti qua e due
occhietti più grandi e qua e lo mettiamo
subito qui
questo mio slime quattro cd o quello che
i verdi tranquillità il fermilab rokita
inquietante allora molto allungabile
molto particolare
il colore è carino molto tema halloween
bello scuro e supera allungabile fanno
tutti gli occhietti tutte le altre cose
che ci stanno provando un sacco di
rumore che accadono perché perché
particolare ha fatto apposta tu sei
bellissima
ora che colori questi riflessi blu e
viola stupendo dove lo stupendo molto
tema halloween
dopo tutte le decorazioni e ciao poi
rumori a tanti rumori
è nato tutto come scoppietta poi quanti
guardate che faccio molti auguri di rito
ci siamo quasi di atene bastò per
l'attacco degli heat lining quasi
imparato quindi imparato quadri mi
sapere nei commenti che cosa ne pensate
se talking dai basta bene
si ok ragazzi mi lascerà quali sostanze
votate chi ha vinto vinto io ho vinto
vitale in ballo il conte horror
se volete mettere altri speciali
halloween per i commenti quali altri
speciali di halloween volete vedere era
rilassato quattro cartellini e critica
prossimi video cliccate su quella che
preferite e buona visione
ciao